All right,
well let's do it.
Okay,
so we're here on our first day of shooting for the why I sing music video.
So this shots and Mba side is still running his heart out.
Is there like some real inspiration for this song?
Is there a girl or just,
um,
I just,
I wrote it basically
for what I would want in a relationship.
Right,
right.
What?
Everyone looks fine.
So the ideal girl,
if you're out there,
this is for you and find us fine.
Phil,
we're in DC and they see you street and flagger come out talking to be driving
that.
He's going to be hanging out out of the car here and then Miss Tasha is going to
be like doing,
this isn't like the most ghetto production set up ever.
Why are you smiling?
It's a little too smiley.
Girlfriend just died.
Your girlfriends in the hospital.
You gotta be more,
yeah,
that's right.
One with the eyes.
The less,
less smile.
A little bit more.
Ah,
no smile.
No smile.
Those smile.
Most moms,
it's going to be all in the eyes,
man.
Like that'd be teary.
Close your mouth.
10 Buck your face a little bit just to cover it up.
Ah,
one faster or man fell is taking a break because I think he's been running a
little bit too much.
I can't believe Phyllis throwing up right now.
It feels not feeling so well.
No,
I feel guilty.
I feel like it's my fault.
I ate a two third pound burger with fries three hours ago and that has come out
already.
Even have that much food and then running is always not a good idea.
It's not like you just running that you're running as fast as you've ever run.
Yes I can.
To follow a car.
Sorry.
Just so y'all know,
we're making this video for a hepatitis.
Be aware of this is a serious issue,
especially for us Asian Americans.
It's something that I community deals with a lot.
So make sure you get tested and make sure you are aware one in 10,
one in 10 that Asian Americans have hepatitis B
hold on a whole lot of any tears.
His Irish cops following us for the last 20 minutes now.
So Phil is trying to explain to the cops that we are.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
Just give us a warning.
What's up guys?
This is a two Burmese a video shoot for why?
I see you're still sore from yesterday.
Jason,
this really likes laying down on the grounds.
That's what it is.
Just the half of the shot.
Jason's going to
cry.
He showed me how to act because clearly I can't
scared.
Surprised.
Oh my God.
State three of 'em.
Why seeing music video.
We have Natasha here.
She still with us today
to find out all the time.
There's only
two.
Why I smile?
Where do you voicemail and three,
two,
one voicemail.
Disappointed.
A little bit
sad.
Really Sad.
Sorry.
Awesome.
It's okay.
No,
the hook.
Okay.
How are we doing?
What's hell guys?
Uh,
Phil here.
This is the two of us actually into,
it's kind of weird.
We're waiting for Natasha.
Just hanging out with your
daily routine.
You bite your teeth together.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's a little bit different from what I imagine.
It's like a [inaudible]
manager.
[inaudible]
no,
come over.
It's like get up and then
just wrapped up day six they fight,
they fly all like so.
And I'm done.
She's done pretty good,
like being in a different fear,
cripple tacos
first.
Brian Power,
two cameras going on in the other two
and we'll have one song
right.
Nailed it on the photo.
Another camera.
Okay.
All right guys,
we're wrapping up the last day of the wise thing.
Music video with rooftop or suit.
Yeah,
I started casters sex.
A bite likes films for Toria and Zooey projects and that's a wrap guys.
And the great thing about this music
video is that it's for a good cause for hepatitis B.
So B,
sorta learn more about that on our website.
[inaudible] dot org and be sorta took out the music video.